just easy for the chamber
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
much more gets done in London he rocks
doing his thing
focus got to know today different
meanings lemon office being a media
exploding your stuff I told you I could
change the world with a test that
collect a bunch of guards it's got a
don't mess another mole watch your
stance everybody doesn't matter that you
thought it was place somewhere in them
thought wrong in London now just for an
animal trying to vlog just looking at an
email from Kim Garcia who runs our Manor
experience in division now she's
completely infatuated with how the
social world a k PR in yourself to the
world has led to people doing this a lot
of live events and experiences and very
excited of a to experience a lot of
small businesses here a lot of you who
are watching on a big companies
executives should be doing a lot more in
2017 2018 2019 11 live events small
business and there's a there's a
the state kicker you know coming onto
the summer or a fourth of July
extravaganza that everybody new talent
links to what you need to hit up the
organizers offer them some money and
then you need to make some sort of a set
up there that induces social creative so
you know kind of like creating a
background of work setting up your
improve in a spot that's the best buy
and then putting like digital photos
here by a filter over the twenty
thousand square feet on their ad product
I think vaynermedia's ability to
activate experiences brand activation
that the Kentucky Derby the NFL Draft
you know Coachella just going to end up
becoming a very substantial part of our
business and our world and I definitely
think we're going to focus in the hug
though my wife is going toyou doesn't
chases in the world but I definitely
think we're a lot of you here as Boehner
itself is becoming a much bigger player
in small businesses with cleaner data
what we're doing there I do think that
ten to twenty five thousand dollars of
risk with thousand dollars of risk at a
big event or a big regional or local
event for a lot of your businesses is
super poor so many do you have fashion
brands or startup you know coffees or
moving stripes or things of that nature
and trying to do a lot of influencer
marketing but a blake's way to round out
your your execution and your branding is
to
debate innocence and so you know I think
giving out ad at you know at the
Memorial Day again in your local
community just good strategy just
getting your product out there and so
experience real life stuff realizing
that people are hiking and going to
Coachella and go to our Oaks event more
today now because they want to post it
on their Instagram and and social media
if they is a new behavior that people
need to reconcile and take advantage of
and I do believe that most entrepreneurs
don't think of experience and event
marketing especially as it relates to
follow me I think that there are
katrakas
there are opportunities in all facets
not just which app is next or what what
person's about to become the next big
vlogger or not just alexa and podcasting
equation a huge arbitrage literally two
things that are most of my mind right
now as a marketer are you know how I'm
going to activating its voice podcast
and Alexa and Google home and how I'm
going to activate and take advantage of
people now going to more events major
and minor to promote themselves and how
brands and businesses can interact in
that so
a little bit of a different one Google
to ram something yes bunch of stuff
that's a lot of insight that kid
motivated me yes a London trying to get
a little deeper rah rah
don't be stupid don't be dumb judge me
up a girl from don't be rude if you
don't mind the neighbors they got me son
I'm not homeless end up using man I make
this look easy can topple break or bail
so I would never fail new faces new
demands success chase all your friends
oppressor in the face don't stand in
love with play athletes trust TV shows
how is there no athlete I know with the
last name orange all these oranges
important I've got my yep - Jamaal
Charles in Charge that Jamaal Charles
baby that's not bad at all yeah feeling
pretty good because another thing of
course that companies are doomed the
good thing for big companies is a lot of
times they have an 80 year run and a lot
of people make a lot of money along the
way but sure what big company hasn't
lost so I guess right I mean that's a
very important statement like like like
like
Woolworths IBM like like an IBM stock
ikkyo it's not like it's dead but
walruses it's like like and an IBM is
not what IBM was in 1979 Microsoft is
not what Microsoft was in 1992 you know
Google is not what Google was in 2001
like why didn't go let Facebook happen
like right like what like you know I
mean I don't think people get it like a
course that's what's happening show me I
don't live in Fantasyland doesn't happen
there's not a single client that does
the work that I want them to do yes
period because look first of all if
you're inclined services it will never
happen
like anybody cries about that in client
services should get out of client
services like I hate when people like
all the client doesn't get it this sucks
they're stupid I'm like you're stupid
we're reverse engineers the problem we
solved for them is their problem I don't
care what you need you need you know
chases the client of ours in the US
right like they're huge they have a
million problems and one and when I say
problems the truth is and I'm sure you
guys feel this way they have a million
opportunities right do they want people
to open up bank accounts great there's a
strategy for that do they want to
recruit talent I mean I would tell you a
lot of people who are listening right
now the biggest thing I think so we have
a division called Vayner solutions
it's run by dog Dennis Oh Dennis oh gee
again he pronounced I'm Russian and
can't pronounce his last name you know
when I think about the hundred fifty
thousand dollar audit that we're selling
because we're not Boehner McKinsey yet
and we would normally you know in four
years we're gonna sell what what I'm
about to tell you we would sell four
hundred fifty thousand dollars a bank
listening would reach out to us and say
hey we want you to audit our ability to
acquire better talent for our bank from
a technology and innovation not
developers but marketers and executives
who have digital DNA so that our bank
can survive this inevitable death blow
that whether it's cryptocurrency
or Apple and Google and Amazon and
Facebook's foray into their world this
is what's going to happen to them well
when I think about $150,000 package we
play for the audit and then the output
and the advice and the presentation that
is ridiculous ROI I also am empathetic
to why they don't see that and then I'm
excited for them to not buy it now but
buy for a million dollars in four years
but like that's something I think a lot
of like banks and b2b company should be
hiring us for and then and then the
video output right like I just think
nobody makes the modern day commercial
better than my con
like if you want to spend $300,000 to
make something happen I think our
$150,000 video and $150,000 Facebook ads
and influencers on Instagram will give
you a better chance than any Google or
programmatic any commercial any print so
that's what we strive to do know how
much I'm gonna hide the Chinese invented
only two cameras and I started underdog
AHA but I'm gonna hide it's just work
like there's just no shortcuts it's a
marathon you know like it's a ton of
work it's about being right I love them
people like well you've got to be smart
not just right work hard
oh yeah Gary but you got to work smart
I'm like no [ __ ] dick like yes of course
you have to work smart next the part
that people don't want to do is work
hard like the smart part is not
controllable like either you're smart
about your strategy or not like the hard
part is controllable like you can work
five x four hours a day instead of
watching TV oh go to the pub ya can work
on the weekends like I did for every
single year of my 20s all of them every
year of my 20s I worked on Saturday for
14 hours in the liquor store I don't
know nobody who'd my company works on
Saturday ever so like you know I think
anyway it's an amazing correlation isn't
it do you know how hard this for me to
do this vlog 90% of my meetings are
talking about raises and clients and
salaries and firing and strategizing
about clients work and you know there's
a PR headache we have with a client
right now people are mad at me I can't
speak to it I'm legally obligated like
like you know it's gonna happen to you
the blog has been interesting to me it
is really an interesting piece of
content because I treat it as something
that I would have made for the 15 year
old me right like I learned by watching
like people like Gary you're you know
somebody saw me a mystery yesterday in
London is like Gary you're getting to
motivational I need more details
like you're getting away from who you're
on like you're getting confused this is
who I am
you need to watch what I'm doing I say
don't you know I say it a lot right
watch what I'm doing why am I doing this
podcast you know the you know one of the
five biggest podcast in the world all my
handlers think this is the biggest waste
of 30 minutes ever
this is critiqued as a bad idea now
let's break down why I'm doing it
I think karma is practical I like giving
back to my community I think it's ry+ do
I think you have a million [ __ ]
people listening to this no I do not do
I think that 13 people have never heard
of me before to listen to this and get
on to me I sure do do I think in a
15-year window that that becomes
valuable my 30 minutes because my 30
minutes were probably worth $100,000 now
yeah I do in 15 years do I think in next
15 weeks
I don't 15 months nope 1.5 years
probably not that's it that's how I
think about the world
I thought you I can change the ground
and I'll go when I'm ready hey a bunch
of cards like I thought it is deci we're
not historians we don't look back to
1955 and say who is dominating from 1855
to 1916 you like we don't do that like
we think oh my god my company has been
around for 120 years we're not going
anywhere because they just don't do the
homework
I think voice is gonna be so I would say
I would actually ladder it up I would
say voice I think that podcast ads
becoming a podcast alexis skills these
are all things that are very top of mind
for me one thing that people are
misunderstanding is that time is the
only thing that is driving our behavior
right like like the only thing time is
an emerging thing that's driving our
behavior above and beyond entertainment
escapism things of that nature so you
can correct meaning when you are driving
you are not watching a video you're just
not and so but you have Bluetooth now
and your car has Bluetooth and instead
of the serendipity of whatever the local
station is playing or the music that
you've had on your whatever you know
it's been interesting to watch people
shift from music
consumption to information podcasting is
big big big big big big big big it's
what we're building we just launched a
new division called Manor experience
because I'm they're calling it our
you're a total branded beer because we
think activations matter like we we are
obsessed with activating like there's so
much product to be sold when the Rugby
World Championship was here but every
brand paid a sponsorship has some
cockamamy induce outside of Wembley
Stadium and called it a day
I'm I'm fascinated by how much money
brands are wasting on activations
without making social content created by
people in the batter everybody's making
the cupcake and then at the end going oh
let's do a hashtag like on the sign and
people put that and nobody gives a [ __ ]
when an influencer takes a picture when
that person takes a picture of your
product without you knowing without you
knowing like it happens every day
you guys are in control the narrative
people are seeing it in different lights
some retailers put you on an end cap at
399 others put you on a pedestal for 419
you guys are not in control but you
think you are and you're justifying that
marketing talk because that's how
everybody was taught marketing 40
[ __ ] years ago it's ludicrous this it
stands for act everybody's interpreting
differently
Louis Vuitton go ahead write it down
write down right now two sentences on
Louie Vuitton knock yourselves out let's
see how [ __ ] a line this actually is
this is what marketers think is
happening it's not real what is it what
does that mean it schizophrenic and
think about schizophrenic at all it's
very unethical it's the reality is the
reality it's the real it's the reality
of what is actually happening so yeah
that's what I think Dan yeah how are you
Gary
all right how are you - pleasure okay
Barbie learning learning burgers working
early learning learning wait that's the
day that the two fades away yay what top
of my hands a sister once top of my head
lay on top of backpack breakfast one top
of a fence back home everybody change I
gotta change everybody change but not
everybody grow everybody change
everybody change I've gone into someone
y'all know started on Ozona home
attacked and I hide the Chinese invented
only two cameras and as I started on the
lota home against in a high confronted
minute so if you cameras in the light
[Music]
60-plus on I love it I love it
welcome sighs Regina hello here we are
right we are live at the illa conference
center and yes finally yes the moment
we've all been waiting for I'd be
uncomfortable Gary Vee thank so are you
excited
no nothing else all right excited always
ready Allison
no I just want to thank you again sir
thank you and making the trip I'm fine
over here gonna be short and sweet
yes heading home tonight but uh
super-focused gonna get my [ __ ] together
I'm going to grill it on stage in a
couple bit relax awesome thank you go
see it I'll see you guys next perfect
you got to wrap your head around
realizing how fortunate you are and how
life is only one at-bat and how great it
is and you know you got a jam one step
of time one step at a time one step at a
time and so to me the advice that I
believe in is that like the hard work
and the efforts are are the most
controllable thing and so you need to
keep grinding and if they aren't
happening the way you want them to
you've got to stay patient
there's no other option so I think
patience hard work and just perspective
of reminding yourself while you're doing
it
have you been good yeah hey brother can
see you people yes it is a crazy for my
Korean that the bailments are important
branding but if you have to do just one
thing one person after building a
powerful brands good energy one thing
with an Apple Instagram etcetera what
would that one thing be daily blog I'm
talking in two years under percent and
not painting a face narrative so if
you're on the big problem that people
make or mistake excuse me that problem
that people make when they're building a
personal brand if they want to make this
before they make they want to savor this
or they start a blog or start doing [ __ ]
with a hundred like my blog is going to
suck like it has been like I've done
what do we have to Roxy fifty whatever
I've done two hundred episodes plus and
like eighty four percent of them have
similarities right like I think that if
you're going to document versus creating
then you've got to document your truth
so if you're just like a bro in the
basement of your house trying to become
an eSports celebrities and you kind of
suck at call of duty or League of
Legends your [ __ ] documented like
document go to 7-eleven and buying
burritos like documents like taking this
the the cab to the [ __ ] grocery like
people are genuinely so I think people
think they're trying to paint a
documentary or be on Shark Tank
meanwhile what they should be doing is
doing a reality show like like and if
you just truly yourself you have a much
better chance of success because the
only thing that is unique are you know
it's very cliche like very here like a
[ __ ] snowflake but the truth is
that's true Marcie's boring yeah
do they still don't yes but then what
they have to understand is if they're
boring and not smart and not interesting
and not funny and not attractive
nobody's gonna watch like like you've
got to have something like like we all
like it
even people break out like it is Talent
but if you're not documenting like look
there's an unlimited amount of people
that can win on vlogging and on
Instagram because they're just [ __ ]
hot it may not be that interesting but
if you're building more exposure you're
a model
some people are comedians some people
are is this legend you know like some
you know some people are going to be
what they're going to be so I think I
think that I I think that documenting
makes sense because the other thing is
if you're not documenting as a person
you're pondering you're overthinking
it's about production it's about putting
it out there what's very different than
the old TV world the old music world
that we all grew up with is I think
people overthink their content there's
too much supply and demand issues with
content you can never you know speed
it's the audience too much because
they're not consuming every little thing
you're doing and if they are and I have
that I have a personality where people
get in the rabbit hole and they're there
for a while and then they kick out and
then they kick back in it's no different
than when you're really into an artist
you're all about [ __ ] Lady gaga for
like a year and then you're not for a
year or two and then if God was good
enough in her neck sounds good right I'm
a big believer that you just build the
biggest building by building big
building I don't spend any time tearing
down people's buildings biggest reason I
don't talk a lot about the bad part of
entrepreneurship is I don't want people
to get the misperception and I'm like
I'm an entrepreneur you or not that is
not what I'm saying I'm saying if you're
depressed if you're like sad if you're
going into debt there's people like
going into $100,000 in credit card debt
to start the company they'd never sold
anything in their lives because they
want to put entrepreneur in a [ __ ]
and Saran profile like that scares me
like that's going to have ramifications
but yeah you're right I mean it's you
know everybody's different
I love eating [ __ ] I love the process
I'm only about the journey
I even think subconsciously I leave a
lot of money on the table because I'm
trying to foreplay the outcome like I
think it's so much thin that I'm fine I
like delight because I love it so much
you know so everybody's different
everybody wants stuff I don't want stuff
I don't want a yacht I don't want to
watch I don't want a jet I want the New
York jet but that's about it and
honestly even that I would far prefer if
you told me if I can have it my way
what I take the Jets at 64 or when I
take the Jets at 46 I've taken at 64
I want the grind I want the narrative I
want the legacy I want the documentation
of it because I know it's going to be
way more powerful when I have 27 years
of vlogs I'm showing how I got there
because that's not seeing just Instagram
so when kid rolls up at me at 62 and
goes I don't know I'll be like go watch
daily z12 14,000 86 then right cuz
that's that's your point that's what's
so great about this body of work I'm
gonna have something you know I wish
people I started putting up some older
content I put up a piece on this
remember yesterday from 2008 saying the
same [ __ ] [ __ ] 10 years later I've
been doing this for a long time this was
everyone's like Gary Vee like obviously
I've had some real viral growth in my
personal brand last six months it's
definitely taken a different leap but
people like oh you're you know you blew
up overnight I'm I talked me I'm like
really I'm an 18 year old entrepreneur
yep and I started a business what
question and I know I'm meeting you
today in question should I be asking you
that's a great question actually so I'm
going to answer that slightly different
I'm going to answer it with anything
that allows me to say something that
makes you realize don't give a [ __ ]
about anything for the next 18 years if
I can convince every 18 year old
entrepreneur to shut down the emotional
needs for short-term [ __ ] until they're
36 they will all be successful let me
tell you a secret this is a little
secret
the majority of entrepreneurs that you
look up to [ __ ] on you behind your back
because they can see the short-term
[ __ ] behavior the biggest thing I
tell a lot of kids that I fall in love
with emotionally I'm like bro you might
be tricking 93 percent but the 7 percent
that rule the world think you're a clown
and that is the energy that I want to
give the 18 year old how much time you
have and when you're doing short term
[ __ ] and baking the funk and
in capital and not actually building a
business or playing the part we're just
going to parties or renting a yacht when
you don't have it to play the part
you're tricking ninety three percent and
it feels real good the problem is the
seven percent they're going to matter
think you've already lost with them
there's a lot of people that I've
crossed out that everybody thinks is
super cool and they're not going to be
here in six years because I've been
through this before
cool cool very much we gotta appreciate
awesome my pleasure that's some good
stuff
[Music]
[Applause]
you know listen I think you win when you
[ __ ] fall in love with patience and
you love the [ __ ] grind Matthew Gary
how are you here Gary I'm rollin rollin
real Patrick Gary Richard Richard such a
pleasure
hey good to see you got your three
minutes we see such a pleasure James
James such a pleasure anyway but no fun
well my new sorry now changing to mic
recording is in word dear go get meat
sorry tell you what you should do you
should partner with somebody who's a
financial based individual a CFO and
have her or him help you justify the
savings of money had fell only on that
you might be able to sell me but the
problem with me is were already kind of
doing it in a weird way with our cheetah
heart officer like I'm already sold then
you've got ninety nine point three
percent of Leicester market who don't
give a [ __ ] the companies but if you
walk in and say you will save 1.9
million dollars and you have it not the
way you and I intuitively know but you
have in data you will sell a shitload
got it welcome cool the biggest biggest
thing with that model that I'm fearful
of is normally the ROI of the cost
doesn't match the quality of the content
and so I think as long as you deliver on
that then you've got something very real
the problem is the math gets too good
and the person allows it to dilute
there's been a lot of people have
started mastermind and scaled advice
businesses that started with the right
intent yeah and then got [ __ ] in the
best way possible for them because they
made a lot more money I think the only
piece of advice I would give you my man
is there's a very fine line between
being great and being completely full of
[ __ ] and spammy in this model which is
why I don't do it because I don't think
I can control it because I think I'm too
charismatic and good of a Salesman that
it would be so big then I would [ __ ] it
up so bad and I would I would be cliche
of what I make fun of I would just tell
you this is a dip by the way there's why
I'm giving you this advice it's a
foregone conclusion to me that you'll be
okay and it's going to work so that's
nothing about I'm giving you advice I'm
giving you is if you care about your
legacy you need to be very smart that
you don't get to seduce
by the model and all certain people
paying a lot of money for getting
nothing or something they can get online
for free which is why I spend my time
writing books and and speaking and
building an agency because once you're
making about you to make it big you got
to make it shitty yeah it's you know
another set it that way so that made a
lot of sense to everybody here right
that's what happens the thing that you
always want to do is you want to win
with winners and a lot of these models
win with losers so you know you want to
win with winners something to think
about I just my big thing is you've got
to feel good about it and if you don't
and you ask me because that will then
bring in a little back you don't need to
build the biggest business got to feel
good about how you make your money and
if you don't you're vulnerable you're
vulnerable to yourself and you're
vulnerable to the market yeah no problem
I mean I can make a hundred million
dollars a year being me in this model I
don't want to because I don't like the
idea of I can't screen who's taking it
like like to me it's back to this
winners losers thing the model attracts
the wrong moths in its worst form when I
say when I say document don't create
when I say act like a media company when
I say the most important one watch what
I'm doing versus what I'm saying even
think about what's happening here I'm
synthesizing it for you but it's the
what I'm doing versus what I'm saying
this is it man you can build a huge
fanbase you can literally film [ __ ] make
an episode every day put it on Facebook
run five hundred dollars worth of ads
against your fans and [ __ ] own it
because I may fall in love with the
groundskeeper guy yeah she may fall in
love with the really cute midfielder and
he may really like the coach you know
right yes that will work you should let
them put out a song every day on
SoundCloud Spotify every day yeah
quality so
you're so excited who likes the fans for
the road the office' yeah that can be
hard work get me strong they're wrong
their quality is subjective to their own
mind it's why they're artists yeah yeah
yeah well I leave it up okay you've done
that you have nothing else right like
there's no way to win music without
putting out volumes of music so put it
off seven five three yep and Spotify
free yeah and then and that's a joke but
but the reality is the reality answer if
they're good like you know if I think
it's a volume game yeah and I think if
they're good enough that one song could
change everything you've got a remote
you got it look I think you know
d-roc and send you this so I can save
them like you can't have your cake and
eat it too
yeah like if you want to be fancy and
subjective about your music and not put
it out
well then you have less chances of
winning so like what do you want
would you like I've good news once you
put our song every day for three years
and then if one of them hits then you
can afford to not put one out every day
yeah yeah yeah I mean I think artists
want their [ __ ] to get out to the world
I think that they're insecure but what
they don't realize it's all subjective
it just subjective like I don't know
like I blog and like there's something I
said in here and they'll edit it and I
don't tell them what they're [ __ ]
edit and maybe it's good maybe it's bad
and like I don't know everyday people
like the best thing you've ever said and
like really it's not [ __ ] or like I'm
like you know like I met Ward the next
day it's I've I think that video crush
that's the smartest [ __ ] I've ever said
I've written four books the best book I
wrote is called Thank You economy Feliz
selling by far thank you you know what I
mean so you know yeah it's just
awareness and the way you get awareness
is running ads on underpriced places or
siphoning awareness from under priced
places there's two places Facebook ads
and influencers like I am a broken
[ __ ] record like it's what you know
it's you rock what episode into the
did you say how are we going to create
something interesting everybody is true
the truth episode 3 episode 3 d Rocco's
you know I don't see this the vibe was
you were concerned you're like you're
like how is it going like interesting
yeah that's what I'm thinking right yeah
what are we gonna do doing I like not
really and he's always saying things
like look if we made this 8 seconds
instead of 30 or this and he's right
he's right the data shows he's right but
I'm trying to prove a macro point yeah
you much fun this is going to be for me
because I'm doing this everyday rest of
my life it's fun this is going to be for
me in 20 years when I get to kill a kid
go watch all 7,000 episodes of daily be
to understand you know pissed i am i
don't have this for the last 20 years of
my life you know how weird episode 1
through 10 years through 3600 would have
been of everyday being at the liquor
store you're much more impactful that
would be it's one thing when I say it
right notice how I'm even saying it in
detail how more impactful it is imagine
seeing it imagine literally literally as
you got into me were like oh look at
daily B look sweet that was Monday that
was like liquor store liquor store
liquor store liquor style yes there yeah
so from 2006 to 2011 200 episodes a year
250 episode I mean I did a thousand
episodes in five years like 200 up to
four years like 200 plus episodes I eat
like five years week no good when I make
those videos once a while that you guys
never want to make which is 11 minutes
of every episode of wine that we can you
just flashing they're like no it's not
going to do well I know it's not going
to do well I'm just making a point
we will excuse me she doesn't need to
get into really where we going you think
I'm dating it off
hell yeah came over boy thank you it was
going on back all right
certainly sure bro hey guys sorry minute
Hey
yeah baby how are you good thanks
alright my god hello man I hadn't even
change my [ __ ] eyes with a pillow my
[ __ ] and you made me put this
together
[Applause]
okay Wow here's what I think I think
that information is commoditized there's
so much information on the internet it's
hard to sell information in my opinion
and feel good about it because there's
so much of it there's a reason my
content is free it's because the supply
and demand of content is harder than
ever to sell and differentiate if you
want to feel great about it because
there's so much content is your $300
thing actually available for four hours
of google searching is your $100 thing
actually available for $9 interest yes
I'll save you time as you debate it you
know zero people zero people that
actually created well I don't mean
you're lucky friend who inherited his
grandmother's mom I need you don't know
anybody on earth that created an actual
business and made wealth without working
their [ __ ] face/off there is no such
thing as passive income it doesn't exist
you might have something that's working
for a little while because you did
landing page optimization and you
figured out how to arbitrage Google for
a few seconds okay a couple of years but
that will go away when Google changes
its algorithm or when people go to
mobile devices or when Facebook becomes
more important which means it was
working for 24 months or 16 but now it's
not which is everything but passive
because you start building your life on
it and then when [ __ ] hits the fan you
have to adjust and it really [ __ ] you
up so these are the big things that I
think about which is why are so many
people looking for shortcuts
as long why are people not willing to do
the tried and true thing when if you
just audit every single situation it's
always the same thing which is the
people that run marathons win and the
people that are running sprints leaves
and it's because people lack patience
people are seduced by stuff people make
all their decisions on short-term money
because they want stop people are
insecure and not posture in front of
other people that they're successful
they're just another [ __ ] reasons why
you do it but it just doesn't make it
right
so how about a little bit of a mission
you know if my big thing is I build
other businesses and then the garyvee
stuff is kind of like out there and the
other thing sure it leads to
opportunities but for me it's I'm on a
mission for legacy around this I'm not
you know I'll get other paid to come and
speak I'll write my books but I'm not
trying to create content as a top of the
funnel thing to sell something at scale
I'm not against that I know the far
majority people want to do that Mazel
Tov knock yourself out it's just not the
way I see it because I don't think
that's how the trends play out and if
you're good enough you don't need it so
these are things that keeps playing over
and over in my mind over and over in my
mind over and over my mind
sinks and high altitudes very high the
competition is real every single person
this room is competing with each other
no matter how they position we're
slightly positioned because we're going
into an attention that we only have so
much attention time is the asset I want
you to understand why I do the things I
do because I know that the tactics I've
laid out over and over and over and over
again you guys confer baiting or keep
some of my [ __ ] if you need to
understand why this is the only thing
that will ever have value is if you
understand people desperately figure out
how to prove
I have more value than you're asking for
them in return and that is where almost
everybody breaks everybody is selfish
you want the money you want the thing
you don't want to provide more value
than that thing is worth you actually
want to do it the other way and by the
way when I say you my time of the search
on the whole [ __ ] game everybody it's
like social security that breakthrough
because when everybody's doing the same
[ __ ] they don't wait and all these
systems look the [ __ ] same and they
all do the same thing it forces
everybody in the same behavior then I'm
nurse'll even like a few people break
through because they go the other way
everybody goes left or the right that's
where all the [ __ ] action is all the
action is in one place in the world
where everybody is creating content for
the Internet which is where everybody's
odds over over and over only a few can
break through because they're providing
more value in return and they have
patience to not ask for money in the up
front but they actually build something
and then are able to extract value later
and I just I don't know I'm worried that
everybody is getting pushed into things
that they're not instead of blocking it
out and going all in on who they are
because that's just where it's going to
be that just slide and show I want to
get ready for Q&A so let's get them like
so and if you have a question so
pointing up their hands let's definitely
go with that little girl who went first
hold on hold on hold on what's your name
little girl
[Music]
well I'd like them do you want to come
up here and give them to me how are you
thank you can I have a hug thank you
written three books Jesus my name is
Rainer Dean everything these going to
become leg astrophotographer wait I
think with I need pictures but I want to
send a message to others
hello being an art museum
we're using a human of me while you're
living out of it we should actually try
to be more of a personality around it so
I initially how would you market the
baby so you want to be somebody that
tells other artists that it's not about
selling the art it's that you need to
build a personal brand to be the
personality behind the art and then
that's the monetization because then
people will buy your art or because then
you can do something else okay so that
that's
I mean first I would not tell them how
to modify so the biggest artists in the
world are self promoters and marketers
of their brand and then they sell the
art so the first one to me is a far more
interesting conversation because artists
are artists for a reason there's a
reason all those people want to take
those photos or paint those pictures
it's because it's what they're good at
or they like or it's what they loved so
forcing them into like forget that the
art is the gateway for you to be a
personal brand and monetize that I think
is just a bad strategy right
you just have entrepreneurial DNA in you
that happen to match along with the art
and that's actually a rarity right
most people don't carry both this is
what I'm to be very frank concerned of
the thought that the model is let's take
them out from what they want to do or
what they want to be doing and I'm going
to teach them how to build a personal
brand the first question becomes why are
you the right person we do that like
have you done that doing what have you
have you made money not being the artist
but you're making money using art as the
gateway yeah how how are you making
money okay Mary your blog right now
making a living doing is shooting the
gloss is
right so so first notes okay it's a good
strategy here's the problem too many
people want to go into teaching people
how to make money a different way before
they've actually ever made money without
making money teaching people how to make
money I mean for me what gave me the
audacity to talk about business was in
my 20s for 12 years without saying a
[ __ ] word to anybody
I built a 60 million dollar retail
business that made me feel like oh let
me tell you what I did or what I thought
about so I think the big thing that
concerns me is I think vlogging and
building awareness and documenting
that's do it because that's going to
bring you attention my friends attention
is the currency of our society
the number one arbitrage in our world
it's called Fame right get real famous
and the weirdest [ __ ] happens people
give you everything for free makes no
sense it's been you know like it's the
number one arbitrage so getting people
to care about you for you and your
journey is important what you do with
that power and how you make money is
even more important that's the thing to
think about so I would say before you
tell people how to make money about it
you need to do that for yourself first
figure out what that was and then do it
you're welcome
[Applause]
can you devote because I push a lot of
people to both when I hear that I'm like
[ __ ] man just do me a huge favor and
audit every other hour right like that's
the tough one right when the head and
heart are aligned magic when the head
and heart are pulling in opposite
directions back to why I was scared with
artists right they're not going to be
aligned that sucks
, I need to know everything you do every
hour you're awake because if I could
audit it carefully I think you might be
doing enough dumb [ __ ] that doesn't
matter
that will let you do both like you know
it's a very interesting thing right like
like how many hours by the way I think
six or seven hours a night and I think
it's always funny that people think it's
a like yeah I only sleep three hours
like sleep is a non debate like you need
it so like but I'm asking this carefully
how many hours are like to you 10 asleep
tell shoes do not lie good sleep seven
like you do one less hour right you just
told me very passionately that your head
and your heart are pulling in opposite
direction that's worth 7 vs 8 comma how
much telly do you watch how many beers
do you drink
how many YouTube videos do you watch how
many [ __ ] conferences do you come to
here's what I know I believe that you
have enough time to do both especially
if any of them has anything to do with
the internet guys every one of our
grandparents didn't have this if they
had a job and they wanted to build
another business that means they need to
be there they can have a [ __ ]
internet we're so lucky let's take
advantage of it we're the first
generation no matter what our region
that's living through this internet
thing that's bonkers [ __ ] crazy good
that's worth chipping away you should
sit down right now not listen to a word
I'm saying and write down every [ __ ]
thing you do seven days a week
you've got family you know you've got
things people have things but you have
enough time for both if you want it
don't you wanna change the waters when
academyofone like you need to make the
part of the fun
nothing changing the flow adjustment
when no people in a great discussion
ceases Rick Rubin will play on Friday
gentlemen of Astana plumber new sorry
now changing to mic recording kazi's
where they're gonna get me sorry I
dropped aspartame Alain no uncover okay
nice okay and you do still trying to say
the tipple day ever gone good that's
great
okay so much change like rearranging
nothing to say just wanted to thank
everybody for watching the vlog means so
much to me obviously this is from Friday
in London Sunday afternoon right now get
ready for week super focused super
revved up great do some serious damage
lot going on so much opportunity the
mindset thing either you're excited
about or you're not I'm ridiculously
excited about it and I see all the
opportunities in hand practitioner ship
architecture optimism I know in the back
a and you're still trying to say the
tipple stay never gone good that's great
okay so much change like rearranging
nothing to say